Diese Polizisten in Ägypten hatten eigentlich
den Auftrag, eine Bank zu bewachen.
Doch dann machte eine Passantin sie auf einen
kleinen Jungen aufmerksam, der an einem Wohnungsbalkon
hing und drohte abzustürzen.
Genauso kam es auch.
Einer der Polizisten konnte den Jungen auffangen.
Nach Angaben des ägyptischen Innenministeriums
konnten die Eltern ihr Kind unversehrt in
ihre Arme schließen.
Die Mutter bedankte sich bei der Polizei für
ihren Einsatz.
Wie der Junge in die schwierige Lage kommen
konnte, war zunächst nicht bekannt.
Der Polizist, der ihn aufgefangen hatte, soll
bei seiner Rettungstat leicht im Gesicht verletzt
worden sein.